[Musique]
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais je me suis mise en tenue
tlx en rouge et noir pour être dans le
ton de l'évènement un petit peu comme en
recherche d'emploi quand on demande à un
candidat de s'adapter à l'interlocuteur
qui est face à lui que ce soit le
recruteur que ce soit le poste que ce
soit l'entreprise que ce soit
l'environnement
et justement c'est mon sujet de ce soir
la recherche d'emploi alors avant de
commencer j'aimerais bien savoir si vous
êtes intéressés par le sujet donc est ce
que ceux qui se sentent concernés
peuvent lever la main alors on peut voir
qu'il ya des personnes qui à priori ne
se sent pas concerné par le sujet alors
moi je vais en faire de déduction soit
vous êtes étudiant soit vous êtes en
poste
alors si vous êtes étudiant vous êtes
plutôt cool
vous avez le temps vous pouvez
procrastiner un petit peu vous avez tout
le temps devant vous et justement grosse
erreur parce que quand on a pas ou peu
d'expérience
la seule chose qui fonctionne très bien
pour ouvrir les portes des entreprises
c'est le réseau alors je précise pour
les étudiants qui sont dans la salle
j'ai dit le réseau je n'ai pas dit le
piston de papounet et de mamoun est le
réseau vous savez le réseau qui se
prépare très en amont
ce réseau qui fait qu' on doit accepter
de donner avant de recevoir ce réseau
qu'on ne peut pas solliciter comme ça
juste au moment où on en a besoin
donc ça c'était pour les étudiants
maintenant si vous êtes en poste je peux
supposer que vous êtes bien au chaud que
vous vous dites peut-être que ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres et je vous le
souhaite
alors je souhaite pas que ça arrive aux
autres mais disons que je ne vous
souhaite pas
que ça vous arrive à vous de vous
retrouver du jour au lendemain au
chômage sauf que si du jour au lendemain
vous perdez votre job
il ya de grandes chances que vous
ressembliez à ça un candidat de la
préhistoire
pourquoi parce que la recherche d'emploi
évolué aussi vite que la société la
recherche d'emploi et vous lui aussi
vite que les technologies la recherche
d'emploi que vous avez connu hier qui
était la vôtre ne sera pas celle
d'aujourd'hui et ne sera certainement
pas celle de demain
alors je vois que certains d'entre vous
peuvent se dire mais après tout rien à
faire je peux très bien être un candidat
de la préhistoire
j'avais un bon job j'avais un bon
parcours
j'avais un bon salaire j'avais des
bonnes mission j'étais dans le bon
secteur
je vais retrouver facilement
et bien si c'était aussi facile que ça
je pense que je ne serai certainement
pas là devant vous ce soir
donc si vous êtes amenés vous aussi à
vivre l'expérience de la recherche
d'emploi et bien comme beaucoup de gens
qui la vivent
vous pouvez avoir mal et vous pouvez
souffrir parce que la recherche d'emploi
c'est aussi ça alors savez vous quelle
est en première position ce qui fait le
plus mal aux chercheurs d'emploi au
hasard dans au hasard dans la salle le
silence ce fameux silence des recruteurs
et je pense que vous l'avez déjà vécu
vous avez connu des gens qui l'ont vécue
c'est à dire vous voyez une offre
d'emploi vous la lisez et vous vous
dites mais c'est tout moi le post me
correspond parfaitement l'émission les
prérequis le diplôme l'expérience ce
poste est fait pour moi et je suis fait
pour le poste et la super motivation
vous y aller à fond et donc vous
enquêtez sur l'entreprise vous enquêtez
sur le recruteur vous enquêtez sur le
secteur vous faites un cv carte de
visite
ultra adaptez vous faites un mail de
motivation ultra motivés
et vous envoyer et justement il se passe
rien le silence et vous attendez vous
attendez vous attendez plus vous
attendez plus vous souffrez et
apparemment ce poste qui était
évidemment pour vous celui qui est en
face le recruteur il n'a pas l'air de
trouver que c'est aussi évident donc ça
c'était la première souffrance et celle
qui est vraiment ressort le plus ce
fameux silence des recruteurs la
deuxième concerne ces fameuses questions
discriminante vous savez les questions
que les recruteurs ne sont pas censés
poser dans les entretiens mais qui vous
pose à chaque fois alors on y va
quel est votre date de naissance quel
est votre âge est ce que vous êtes
mariés ce que vous avez l'intention de
vous marier si vous êtes marié que fait
votre mari avez vous des enfants quel
agent vos enfants si vous avez des
enfants
avez vous prévu d'en avoir d'autres si
vous n'en avez pas est ce que vous avez
prévu d'avoir des enfants et que faisait
vos parents et que faisait votre papa
que faisait votre maman est est ce que
vous aviez des frères et soeurs de quel
milieu venez vous quels sont vos
opinions politiques quelles sont vos
opinions religieuses quelles sont vos
orientations sexuelles
vous souffrez de handicap lequel quels
sont vos maladies et jusqu'à même la
semaine dernière quel est votre poids
donc j'ai demandé à la jeune femme qui
s'appelait jane d'essayer de savoir
pourquoi on voulait connaître son poids
en entretien et bien c'est parce qu'en
fait elle était en surpoids et elle
devait faire des voyages et le recruteur
avait peur d'avoir à payer deux places
d'avion pourquoi elles vous font
souffrir ces questions discriminante
c'est parce qu'elles sortent du cadre de
l'entretien et vous n'avez qu'une envie
c'est de dire aux recruteurs qui sort du
cadre
sauf que si vous lui dites qui sort du
cadre c'est vous qui sortez du processus
de recrutement deuxième souffrance
la troisième concerne les seniors le
pire pour un senior c'est de se
retrouver face à un recruteur qui
pourrait être son enfant donc un
seigneur de 50 ans face à un recruteur
de 25 ans qui ne connaît pas le métier
qui peut même le mettre en difficulté
parce que lui même est en difficulté et
ça pour les seniors je parle
vraiment connaissance de cause puisque
j'en suis c'est une grande souffrance
également mais les jeunes aussi quand
ils cherchent du travail ils ont des
difficultés la première c'est ce fameux
manque d'expérience et alors là c'est
serpent qui se mord la queue parce que
les jeunes ont envie d'hurler de dire
mais comment voulez vous que j'ai cette
fichue expérience si vous ne me
permettait pas d'avoir de l'expérience
sous prétexte que je n'ai pas
d'expérience un truc complètement
aberrant pourtant tous les jeunes se
retrouvent face à ça et la dernière
souffrance aimé y en a plein d'autres
mais j'ai fait un top 5 de celle qui
revenait le plus souvent la dernière
c'est votre regard à tous je sais pas si
vous avez vu vous arrivez dans un
endroit public dans une fête et puis on
vous dit et toi tu fais quoi dans la vie
et là essayer dire je suis chercheur
d'emploi fait encore mieux
je suis chômeur et vous verrez que c'est
magique
vous devenez instantanément transparent
invisible plus de job ou pas de job pas
d'identité et donc par rapport à ses
souffrances
il y en a 1 5 mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres moi je conseille une chose je
conseille aux personnes que j'ai
accompagné que je continue à accompagner
je leur conseille de voir la recherche
d'emploi comme un jeu donc je ne vous
cache pas que quand en atelier ou en
formation
je dis aux chercheurs d'emploi ben voilà
maintenant on va jouer je ne déclenche
pas un enthousiasme général et voir à
peu près systématiquement il ya
quelqu'un qui lève la main et qui me dit
écoutez madame de foucault si vous
croyez que j'ai envie de jouer avec vous
moi dans trois mois sur rsa donc votre
idée du jeu et là je vous la fais police
mais justement c'est ça l'idée c'est
pour pas être dans trois mois au rsa que
en jouant on est meilleur alors vous
connaissez tous le jeu du monopoly
bon si vous tombez sur la case prison au
monopoly que vous passez votre tour et
que vous ne touchez pas
vingt mille ou que vous tombez sur rue
de la paix qui est un hôtel rouge et que
vous perdez
est ce que vous vous dites que vous êtes
désespéré est ce que vous dites que le
monopoly c'est nul et que c'est un jeu
débile
non vous allez au bout de la partie et à
la limite vous faites d'autres partie de
monopoly
quand vous perdez une partie de poker
est ce que vous êtes désespéré bon alors
oui si vous avez joué de l'argent mais
imaginons que vous n'ayez pas jouer
d'argent vous vous dites simplement vous
n'aviez peut-être pas les bonnes cartes
en main vous n'avez pas une chance
et puis peut-être qu'il a mieux le fait
que vous votre adversaire et si vous
prenez un sport enfin jeux de sport et
bien vous êtes face à votre adversaire
on va jouer au tennis il vous bat bon
vous lui en voulez certes mais vous
allez aussi vous dire que vous manqué
peut-être d'entraînement il y aura
d'autres partis tennis vous n'allez pas
abandonner le tennis pour autant l'idée
du jeu en fait c'est de concentrer le
peu de force qui nous reste
quand on est chercheur d'emploi pour
l'essentiel ne pas utiliser son énergie
à essayer de lutter contre tout ce qui
est inadmissible en recherche d'emploi
parce qu'il ya énormément de choses qui
sont inadmissibles mais de se concentrer
justement sur le but à atteindre et qui
est finalement le job
la deuxième idée c'est que si vous ne
réussissez pas votre recherche d'emploi
ça ne veut pas dire que vous êtes un
mauvais professionnels
personne ne pourra jamais vous enlevez
votre expertise métier et la personne
que vous êtes les compétences que vous
avez les soft skills que vous avez
par contre ça veut juste dire que vous
êtes un mauvais chercheurs d'emploi
maintenant est ce que c'est un but dans
la vie d'être un bon chercheur d'emploi
je ne suis pas certaine mais disons que
si vous voulez être un bon chercheur
d'emploi qu'est ce que donnerait la
recherche d'emploi vu comme un jeu ben
c'est vous le petit bonhomme et vous
voyez que vous êtes finalement sur la
case départ et sur la case arrivée assez
loin se trouve le job de vos rêves ou le
projet de vos rêves et avec beaucoup de
parcours c'est comme un labyrinthe et
puis vous avez envie d'avancer
puis là attention faut pas partir tout
de suite dans le jeu il faut se poser
les bonnes questions
qui suis-je qu'est ce que je sais faire
qu'est-ce que je ne sais pas faire
qu'est-ce que je ne
veut plus faire où est ce que je suis
bon ou est-ce que je ne suis pas bon
qu'est-ce que j'ai besoin d'améliorer
vous pouvez aussi vous faire le deuil
le deuil de votre ancienne entreprise le
deuil de votre ancien stage le deuil de
votre vision idéalisée de la recherche
d'emploi et pour ça c'est bien d'être
aidés dans le jeu avant de démarrer donc
vous dites ça y est je c'est bon je sais
où je vais je démarre non parce qu'il
faut prendre le bon personnage et donc
dans la partie je ne suis pas un
demandeur d'emploi demandeurs c'est une
position basse vous êtes un chercheur
vous êtes proactif vous êtes un offreurs
de services à nos frères de compétences
un expert dans votre métier
et là vous pouvez démarrer et vous avez
évidemment des obstacles face à vous ces
fameux recruteurs qu'on appelle aussi
des ennemis alors une petite précision
parce que je suis un ancien recruteur
le recruteur quand il se réveille le
matin il se dit pas yes super journée
je le faire dix candidats dans la
journée je vais les faire souffrir à
mort et ce soir je serai content de ma
journée
le recruteur il a un objectif comme vous
faut qu'ils trouvent la bonne personne
pour le bon job qu'ils soient dans un
cabinet qui soit dans un service rh
qu'ils recrutent pour lui même et en
plus comme vous il a peur il a peur de
se tromper
donc vous avez la même peur et le même
objectif et l'idée dans le jeu c'est de
faire de cet ennemi un ali après il ya
les différentes voies à prendre et on
les regarde ensemble est-ce que je ne
réponds qu annonce est-ce que je ne
réponds est ce que je ne fais que des
candidatures spontanées ce que je fais
du réseau est ce que je suis sur les
réseaux sociaux
et peut-être que je peux tout faire à la
fois ça va dépendre des stratégies et de
six passes puis comme c'est aussi un jeu
de chance vous allez voir que certaines
fois vous allez avancé trois cases
d'autres fois vous allez reculé de 4
cases vous allez voir des gens qui sont
partis après vous qui vous dépasse et
puis il ya un jour où vous allez réussir
et vous aurez même ce qu'on appelle le
choix du roi c'est à dire la possibilité
de choisir et plus vous allez jouer et
plus vous allez être bon c'est
mathématique
il n'y a pas une seule personne qui
puisse est bonne en recherche d'emploi
si elle ne s'est pas entraîné avant donc
qu'est ce que ça donne
de jouer et de considérer la recherche
d'emploi finalement comme un grand jeu
de société par rapport aux 5 souffrance
que l'on a vu précédemment
mais imaginons que vous êtes vous pouvez
être ces deux candidats donc vous voyez
qu'il y en a un os qui traîne sa
mallette qui traîne sa souffrance c'est
celui qui luttent contre ce qui est
inadmissible et il ya tellement de
choses inadmissibles qu'il est vraiment
pas bien
puis à celui qui a décidé de jouer et
vous pouvez être celui qui a décidé de
jouer qui va plus vite et qui glisse sur
sa sacoche
donc le silence ça donne quoi eh ben
c'est un jeu donc je sais que de toute
façon j'aurais du silence personne ne
répondra ou pas beaucoup de monde
répondra à mes candidatures
c'est pas parce que je suis mauvais ce
sont les recruteurs qui sont mauvais
mais je les accepte c'est une des règles
du jeu et là je peux être proactif je
prends mon téléphone
j'en vois des mecs j'essaie de contacter
sur linkedin pourquoi pas et j'essaye de
savoir pourquoi il ya le silence et si
ça marche pas c'est pas si grave et je
tente autre chose quand je réponds à des
annonces j'ai du silence bombe à ce
moment là je vais plutôt faire du réseau
j'ai moins de silence première façon de
jouer le deuxième piège rappelez-vous
enfin la deuxième souffre en ce qui
concerne ces fameuses questions
discriminante
vous pouvez décider de lui répondre
personnellement moi ça me gêne pas quand
on me demande mon âge 53 ans pourquoi
pas si on me demande mon toit là je suis
un peu moins bien j'ai pas envie de
donner mon poids ou alors bon donc seule
chose qu'on peut faire c'est comme
faisait une de mes candidate qui
s'appelait jane et qui nous racontait
elle était très jeune et à chaque fois
lui demander est ce que vous avez prévu
de vous marier ce que vous avez prévu
d'avoir des enfants et un jour elle a
décidé de prendre une tête triste et de
dire je ne pourrai jamais avoir d'enfant
il n'y a jamais eu de deuxième question
personnelle et donc dans l'atelier les
gens lui disent oui mais attends là tu
es en phase finale si tu prends le job
et que tu tombes enceinte et elle très
tranquillement réponds bah je dirais que
c'est un miracle
et alors attention ne commencez pas à
tous dire sur les réseaux que christelle
de foucault a dit qu'on pouvait mentir
en entretien sauf que quand le recruteur
sort du cadre vous êtes en droit dans la
partie dans le jeu de sortir du cadre
également mais ça c'est chacun qui il
voit donc moi personnellement je dirais
que je fais 20 kg de moins ça ne me
gênerait pas du tout de sortir du cadre
par rapport à la souffrance du senior
qui se retrouve face à ce recruteur qui
pourrait être son enfant et bien moi
j'ai connu un monsieur que ça fait
pascal qui a été les deux sa hantise il
avait 55 ans à anti c'était d'être face
à ce recruteur jeune et il en avait fait
un cheval de bataille si bien que à
chaque fois qu'ils étaient face à un
recruteur jeune il oublier tous ces buts
et son but c'était de le mettre en
difficulté et dont qui lui posait des
questions pièges lui-même y mener
l'entretien il lui disait des trucs
incompréhensive il était dans la gestion
de projets et cetera et évidemment le
recruteur est en difficulté comme c'est
un être humain il ne recrutait pas
pascal et pascal nous a régalé pendant
six mois de ces anecdotes parce qu'il
avait beaucoup d'humour
sauf que moi à la fin d'un atelier je
suis allé le voir et je dis me calé dans
votre but dans la vie est ce que c'est
de former tous les jeunes recruteurs de
france ou est ce que votre but dans la
vie c'est de trouver un job et il s'est
trouvé que la fois d'après il était face
à un jeune recruteurs de 23 ans il a
regardé avec l'amour d'un parent il a
aidé ils ont créé une alliance
ensemble ils sont allés vers le poste
qu'il a eu le poste grâce à un jeune de
23 ans les jeunes vous qui êtes jeunes
on vous la posera cette question et vos
repas tapas d'expérience bah oui c'est
normal je suis jeune attendez vous à
cette question mais soyez fiers nous
seigneur nous donnerions n'importe quoi
pour être jeune
le monde vous appartient vous êtes
ouvert vous êtes ouvert roland vous est
ouvert aux frontières profiter de votre
aisance vous êtes des digital natives
ce qui va compter pour le recruteur
c'est parce que vous avez fait c'est
parce que vous savez faire c'est ce que
vous serez capable de faire et la
manière dont vous allez vous adapter aux
nouveaux métiers et par rapport à la
dernière question
quand on vous dit et toi qu'est ce que
tu fais dans la vie vous pouvez tenter
je suis en transition professionnelle
ça mange pas de pain ou faire comme
certains j'en ai plusieurs qui faisait
ça qui disait je suis chercheur dans une
des plus grandes entreprises françaises
donc verser un peu l'idée du jeu et ce
que je voudrais qu ensemble c'est qu'on
se pose la question et si tous ensemble
nous décidions in pour une bonne fois
pour toutes de faire en sorte que la
recherche d'emploi soit une grande aire
de jeu afin de lui donner un air de joie
et surtout pour moins souffrir
merci
[Musique]